we have that card with a little round
hole in it and what I want you to do is
hold it up and try to cast a shadow on
that wall there and I want you before
you do it to predict what we're going to
see cut out the car shatter the car a
little hole in it will see that figure
enlarged on the wall it's not very
pronounced but you can actually do see
the little holiday and of course me so
cool
my next question for you is we have this
card what's that like let's pick a hole
can you tell me what size circle we're
gonna see like compared to the other one
yeah twice the size maybe but still the
card with a larger round hole what do
you see bigger hole the card and the
hole slightly bigger than the previous
one and the same thing just larger okay
what I want you to do same size though
it's approximately the same size as the
lawn why don't we compare it here you go
hey Ron it is ones just fine to the
other well goodness it actually looks
about the same same size hole okay I
can't believe that it's must be the Sun
playing tricks with my mind
what about here's really gonna test you
right tell me about what's on that card
before you put it up trying yeah okay so
what do you expect it will see on the
wall a triangle but I wouldn't be
surprised it wasn't so cool what are we
gonna see your angle I'm dreading okay
let's have a look oh wow that's all good
for me
cool it'll be a triangle well we're not
gonna see a triangle I'm not guess
everything else has been a circle so
it'll be a circle I'm sticking to
triangle okay
have a look I'm interested well there
you go it's so cool
you want to compare it to the one of the
others I'll give you the one do you want
oh my goodness I really like this
project I'm learning something the Sun
is definitely playing tricks my mind the
Sun is deceptive actually why are we
seeing circles with all these cards
regardless of the shape of the whole I
really don't know I'd like to know when
you take away the definition from any
kind of shape it ends up being just
round to our eyes there for example you
get a perfect triangle but it was a
pretty decent circle so MA see you must
get to a certain size here doesn't
matter that what shape it is it's just
turned back probably why is it going to
a circle though you look at the Sun it
looks it around doesn't it I'm not sure
if that's got anything to do with it
well the light is going through these
little holes and it is the Sun the sun
rays just sort of um going through the
pseudo holes making circle of the Sun I
don't know you tell me exactly you know
that what we're looking at there is
actually an image of the Sun yeah Wow
that's round in the Sun Tran yeah the
Sun the sun's round I guess things
around the buildings round is it my
buddy's not round so what we're seeing
is a projection of the Sun I've never
thought about it before I think that you
actually know and I think you have
actually thought about it but you're not
cueing that right part of your brain
that knows the answer
yeah probably there's a part of your
brain that knows the answer well I did
photography at school um and we did
pinhole cameras the hole actually
reflects what it's showing on the wall
so so you see what you see on the other
side what's that so it's a Sun well
there you go that's something today
Derek